this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skillshare learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on the link in the description
authorities say that the eldorado forest
fire that is currently burning out of
control in california
was started at a gender reveal party
when a couple detonated a
smoke-generating pyrotechnic device to
announce to the world that their unborn
baby was
a son the device ignited the four foot
tall grass at the el dorado ranch park
on a day when most of california was
being roasted by temperatures of over
100 degrees
so far thousands if not millions of
acres have burned allegedly as a result
of this gender reveal party
hundreds of firefighters are battling
the blaze and thousands of people have
had to evacuate
so congratulations it's a fire and
because we live in the dumbest timeline
gender reveal parties have actually
sparked at least four disasters
including two forest fires a plane crash
and a person killed by what was
effectively a pipe bomb
seriously why do people do this why do
they think it's a good idea
but this raises a different legal
question shouldn't the people whose
actions start wildfires be held
responsible for the damages
to life and property well the eldorado
blaze was just one of several fires that
continued to burn
up and down the west coast as extreme
heat created hazardous conditions
and therein lies the first of many
problems in assigning blame in recouping
costs
here allegedly a couple started a fire
but how do you decide if they have
liability and if so when millions of
acres burn
where does their liability end and who
normally pays for damages caused by
massive fires
and finally if billion dollar fires are
more common because of climate change
how will the law rise to meet this
[Music]
challenge
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because we didn't start the
fire was always burning since the
world's been turning
but thanks to climate change it's
burning a whole lot more often and
in that situation who pays for the
damages caused by these massive massive
wildfires that are currently burning
california and
oregon and in general there are probably
three main sources that are likely to
provide compensation in a situation like
this with forest fires one
is insurance companies though that's
increasingly becoming less likely to
pay for circumstances like these two is
the federal government in other words
taxpayers are likely to pick up the bag
when insurance companies
refuse to and then third of course are
other people people that are responsible
for the fires or people that contribute
to the fires and potentially people who
contribute to global warming well fires
are as old as civilization itself and as
a result we've developed a number of
legal tools to help deal with the
liability that's caused from those
conflagrations
and if you know your american history
you might recall that mrs o'leary and
her cow
were blamed for the great chicago fire
of 1871 which killed 120 people
consumed over three square miles of the
city center and caused 200 million
dollars in damages in today's money
eventually historians concluded that she
was the victim of anti-immigration
sentiment and the city formally
exonerated her in 1997.
but similarly in 2017 rita yaboa a
ghanaian immigrant was blamed for the
deadly bronx apartment fire that killed
13 people
her three-year-old son was playing with
the oven when it caught fire and
yeboa was chastised by local authorities
for not attending to her son and failing
to close the door
these two stories have more in common
than just anti-immigration sentiment
there's no doubt that the chicago fire
was started in mrs o'leary's barn just
like there was no question that the
deadly bronx fire was started in yeboa's
apartment
but mrs o'leary disputed the idea that
she had negligently milked a cow which
allegedly kicked over a lantern and
started the blaze
and similarly yeboa fought back by suing
her landlord for permitting dangerous
conditions in the apartment building
which may have had doors that wouldn't
stay closed
although both women faced social stigma
neither of them had to pay for the
damages to property or the cost of fire
suppression and that's because in
america
fires that weren't intentionally set by
arsonists have historically been treated
as well
accidents however in 2020 massive
wildfires are frighteningly commonplace
and they're taxing our traditional
methods of paying for them
and we'll get to the personal liability
that stems from causing fires as in what
happens when you get sued for causing a
fire in just a second
but let's start with the more
traditional way that people get
compensation for accidents especially
when it comes to homes and fires
which is the insurance industry and for
those who are uninsured or
underinsured fema offers individual and
household disaster assistance that can
help pay for damages to homes and
businesses
generally we're talking about standard
homeowner's policies the insurance
policy that everyone needs when you buy
or own a house
which generally covers destruction and
damage caused by a fire which generally
includes wildfires
in the event of a fire the insurance
company will pay to rebuild or repair an
insured home and remediate smoke damage
this includes the outbuildings on the
property such as a garage or a tool shed
some insurance policies cover theft or
vandalism that happens in the event of
looting in the wake of
wildfire businesses tend to have their
own policies which cover
fire damage to the building office space
and equipment and inventory and of
course insurance is an important piece
of the fire cost puzzle but there are
limits in this case
literally because the amount of the
insurance payout is determined by the
terms and limits of the policy itself
generally homeowner's policies don't
cover limits beyond one to two million
dollars unless the homeowner has paid
for more coverage
and every policy carries exclusions that
prevent the insurance company from
having to pay out if
the situation falls under one of those
scenarios covered by the exclusion
and whenever you have this much property
destruction at exactly the same time
the insurance industry is notorious for
doing whatever it can to avoid
paying out as one of my former law
partners used to say the only thing an
insurance policy is good for is getting
the right to sue your insurance company
already these wildfires in oregon and
california are causing huge losses in
the insurance industry and a few years
ago back in 2018 the campfire fire was
the costliest wildfire in california
history causing more than 14 000
structures to be destroyed
and the insurance industry had losses of
over 14 billion dollars
the scale of those losses in other words
the insurance companies had to pay out
billions of dollars to the people that
bought insurance from them
prompted reinsurance companies to step
back now reinsurance is insurance
purchased by insurance companies that
are offloading some of the financial
risks of a major catastrophe
the availability of reinsurance enables
better known primary carers such as
farmers and state farm to keep riding
coverage in areas that are
most likely to experience wildfires now
while primary insurance companies
generally face tons of regulations that
prevent them from raising prices for
high risk
areas reinsurance companies generally
are not subject to rate regulation by
the california department of insurance
as a result reinsurance rates are
skyrocketing by as much as 70 percent so
since insurers can't raise homeowners
insurance rates because of state
regulations to match the actual
price of the things that they're having
to pay out because of the wildfires
generally because of state regulations
insurance companies have reduced the
number of policies that they underwrite
and some people living in rural
california now have properties that are
effectively uninsurable
so while many homeowners in affected
areas may be able to get a insurance
payout
this year effectively the insurance
companies may leave the area entirely
because
it's too risky and the housing markets
in these areas may
tank because no one's going to buy an
uninsured house especially
in an area that's going to be facing
wildfires year after year
people love to dunk on insurance
companies myself included
but if it becomes too costly to provide
that insurance the insurance company
will just simply leave the market
entirely
but with insurance companies
increasingly refusing to provide
coverage for these kinds of areas that
might mean that the federal government
in other words taxpayers are going to
have to pick up the bill
and when it comes to the cost of
fighting the fires the federal
government has
stepped in to cover some of those costs
the trump administration issued a major
disaster declaration for california
wildfires which
opened up the gates for federal funding
to be funneled into recovery efforts
funding through the declarations covers
up to 75 percent of the costs incurred
by california for
removing debris conducting emergency
activities providing transitional
sheltering and
presumably raking the forests as the
president has told us that we should be
doing
i was with the president of finland and
he said we have
a much different we're a forest nation
he called it a forest nation
and they spent a lot of time on drinking
and cleaning and doing things and
they don't have any problem and what it
is it's a very small problem
you got to take care of the floors you
know the floors of the forest
very important federal funding is also
available on a cost-sharing basis for
hazard mitigation measures statewide
now the federal government has spent
about 1.58 billion dollars on fire
suppression in 2019 and
this is more than triple the amount
allocated in 2018.
unfortunately some of the money that was
allocated to fight fires was shifted
from fire prevention activities and
the west coast fires are often
politicized in a really ugly way
now there is a source of
quasi-governmental entities that
might provide compensation and that
would be the utility companies now
most experts say that extreme weather
conditions that lead to fires are caused
by climate change but
the laws that we have on the books just
haven't caught up with the scale of
these massive fires
this is a big problem for state and
local governments which are left footing
the bill for the cost of fire
suppression and cleanup and sometimes
there's an easy wealthy target for the
state to go after
for example california's department of
forestry and fire protection determined
that 12 devastating fires that struck
northern california in 2017
were the results of trees coming into
contact with power lines or
other failures by the utility company pg
e and thanks to a policy known as
inverse condemnation the utility has to
pay those damages which the company
believes will be over
10 billion dollars and even if the
company is found to be non-negligent
inverse condemnation is a legal doctrine
that holds utility companies like pg
e pacific gas and electric to a strict
liability standard
under strict liability it doesn't matter
if a fire starts by accident or
negligence
if it happens on the company's equipment
then the utility is responsible for
those damages
california court decisions in the 1960s
and 70s allowed the state to use inverse
condemnation to hold utilities liable
for many years the utility companies
could just handle the costs by
increasing the rates charged to
consumers but in 2017 the california
public utilities commission turned down
requests by sdg e
for 379 million dollars in cost
reimbursements for the 2007 wildfires
sparked by their lines now power
companies may be on the hook for actual
costs without electricity hikes
and how they're going to do that is
anyone's guess pg e
filed for bankruptcy protection it
argued that the disallowance amounted to
a violation of the takings clause of the
fifth amendment of the united states
constitution
and the california constitution the
legal theory is that even though the
state did not take any pg e property
applying inverse condemnation to the
company effectively transfers the
company to the state without just
compensation or
any compensation at all and the company
argued that if it was allowed to pass
the costs to consumers through increased
utility rates
inverse condemnation would be
constitutional but a federal bankruptcy
court rejected this argument and the
case is on appeal
in front of the california supreme court
which takes us to the next group of
people who are
likely to face some liability and that
is of course the tort liability of
individuals a tort is a wrong committed
by a person that ends up causing harm to
someone or something else
the tort at stake in wildfire cases is
most likely negligence and black's law
dictionary defines negligence as
the failure to exercise the standard of
care that a reasonably prudent person
would have exercised in a similar
situation
and there are four elements in a
negligence claim duty a breach of that
duty
injury and causation now the two
elements that i want to highlight in a
wildfire negligence case is the duty of
care
and causation because damages are pretty
obvious here now the duty of care is
based on what a reasonable person in the
same or similar circumstance would do
it's an objective test based on what a
reasonable person would have done in the
same or similar circumstances
the circumstances of the eldorado gender
reveal party help us to define whether a
person acted reasonably or negligently
did the people detonate explosives in
their backyard near a pool or were they
in an
area with high flammable dry foliage
what was the weather like was it hot and
dry or cool and rainy had local
authorities warned people that
conditions were dangerous and could
potentially lead to fire
the facts determine whether people acted
reasonably or like idiots
i mean acted reasonably and as i've said
before
if you ask a lawyer anything the answer
is almost always it depends and i try
not to take a stand on
most things but i will go out on a limb
and say that if you are
detonating a bomb in front of a bunch of
dry grass on a 100 degree day
that's probably negligence but that
takes us to the second element of
negligence that's
at play here and that's causation now
there are two types of negligent
causation there's actual cause and
proximate cause and
actual cause is sometimes referred to as
cause and fact it means that
but for the negligent act or the
omission by the defendant
the plaintiff would not have been harmed
this is known as the butt for test
for example if a couple detonates a bomb
in front of a bunch of dry grass on an
incredibly hot dry day
and that grass catches fire and sets
their neighbor's house
on fire then it's clear that the butt
four test is made
but for the bomb going off and the fire
consuming the house the
house wouldn't have been damaged but the
second type of negligent causation is
called proximate cause and proximate
cause requires that the
natural direct and uninterrupted
consequence of a negligent acura
omission
causes the plaintiff's injury for
example the el dorado couple's actions
did start a huge fire but where does
their liability end what if
once the fire had started joe rogan
seeing the fire spreading
decided that he wanted to create a
copycat fire
and blame liberal activists for setting
fires
i'm a little salty because joe rogan is
blaming liberal activists for the fires
which is
insane i said something on the podcast
with douglas murray
about people getting arrested for uh
lighting
fires you know air quote activists and
uh
i got duped obviously the eldorado
couple's actions are a but for cause
seeing the fires led joe rogan to start
a copycat fire
but it's hard to say that their actions
were the proximate cause of the second
fire
spreading and causing damage and
extending this hypothetical even further
what happens if the first fire and the
second fire combine to form
a super fire and then damage other
property who's then responsible for the
damages caused by the combined fire
it's hard to say that's the problem of
proving proximate cause
but back to the real world i think a
jury could be persuaded that the el
dorado couple acted negligently and
cause property damages but
collecting many billions of dollars from
that couple would be a
daunting if not impossible task they're
not jeff bezos but just because someone
might be judgment proof and
can't afford the billions of dollars of
property damage doesn't mean that
they're going to escape
all penalties and there are other
options for local government
with fires on the rise in the west local
and state governments have started going
after people for starting fires
in oregon for example two men were
billed for starting a fire that burned
26 000 acres
over the course of a month and the men
were billed for
37 million dollars in damages they both
used lawn mowers to mow grass during the
daytime
which was prohibited at the time because
the conditions were so hot and dry that
they could cause a fire
which they did but under oregon law the
men could only be fined in accordance
with civil penalties
they were each fined 550 each for a fire
that cost the state at least 37 million
dollars to suppress but california law
provides an additional way to penalize
reckless property owners for example in
2016
the u.s forest service sued a california
property owner seeking almost 25 million
dollars in compensation
for the fire that burned 15 000 acres of
federal lands in san bernardino national
forest
investigators determined that the fire
ignited in a plastic electrical junction
box that wasn't properly sealed
an electrical discharge inside the box
shot sparks onto dry ground vegetation
which sparked a mountain fire the
theories of liability included
negligence trespassed by fire and
violations of california's health and
safety code section thirteen zero zero
one
which allows the state to pass the cost
of fire suppression to any person who
negligently sparks a fire
obviously the plaintiff is unlikely to
get 25 million dollars but the suit
allows the government to negotiate with
an insurance company provided the
property was insured and
sends a message they hope will deter
others from similar conduct
of course if the civil fines and
lawsuits aren't enough a person can be
prosecuted criminally as well
a person can be prosecuted for reckless
or extremely negligent conduct the kind
of thing that we would normally call an
accident
under california penal code section 452
it's a crime for a person to recklessly
set a fire or
burn any structure forest land or
property california penal code section
452
makes it a crime for a person to
recklessly set a fire or to burn any
structure
forced land or property a person acts
recklessly if the person is aware that
their actions could present
a substantial and unjustifiable risk of
causing a fire
the person ignores that risk and
ignoring the risk is a gross deviation
from how a reasonable person would act
in the same situation
a reckless action is a higher standard
than mistakes or even negligence
negligent acts include things like
forgetting to turn off the burner on a
stove this alone won't subject someone
to a reckless burning charge
however acting with complete disregard
for safety may
so for example if you were trying to
heat up
a can of gasoline on the stove that
might qualify
as recklessness you didn't intend for a
fire to start but you should know that
if you're heating up gasoline on a stove
on an open flame
a fire may result from that and basic
reckless burning of personal property
under penal code section 452 is a
misdemeanor with a maximum penalty of
six months in jail
and a fine up to a thousand dollars but
if the reckless burning results in a
burned structure or forest land or if it
causes great bodily injury then the
crime may be prosecuted as either a
misdemeanor or a felony and that's what
happened to william rupp
who served two years in prison for
recklessly causing the lake shasta fire
in 2008.
the 56 year old was accused of
intentionally ignoring warnings of a
potential fire hazard by
cutting the grass on his rural property
on an extremely dry day when
temperatures were about 106 degrees
a mower blade struck a rock sparked and
ignited the fire which burned 86 rural
homes at around 1 30 pm
prosecutors said rupp ignored warnings
not to mow from neighbors and public
service spots on tv
and told one person who questioned him
to go to hell and a similar situation
happened in arizona when an off-duty
border patrol agent was ordered to pay
220 thousand dollars in restitution
after he started a 47
000 acre wildfire at a gender reveal
party again
with the friggin gender reveal parties
in that case dennis dickey pleaded
guilty to the misdemeanor charge of
causing a fire without a permit after he
caused the april 2017
sawmill fire in arizona dickie
reportedly shot a target containing
tananite which is an explosive substance
designed to detonate when shot by a high
velocity firearm
and colored powder that would reveal the
baby's gender at the party
tananite has reportedly been linked to
past wildfires and
featured prominently in tiger king are
you ready for this
oh hell dickie of course claimed it was
a complete accident and that he
immediately contacted authorities
and that's probably true but the problem
with claiming that it's a complete
accident is that there were 40 mile an
hour winds that day in the desert in an
area that had already experienced
drought conditions and you would think
that a reasonable person would know that
a high explosive in dry grass with
fast winds is likely to cause a really
big fire
but if you're throwing a gender reveal
party with explosives then you're
probably an idiot and you need to spend
some time learning how
to not be an idiot and the best place to
learn anything is skillshare and one of
the best classes is thomas frank's class
on real productivity
how to build habits that last and i'll
bet one of the keys to productivity is
not throwing a stupid gender reveal
party
but let me ask him hey thomas stop
throwing gender reveal parties
and just a thought maybe stop starting
fires too
yep thomas is a smart guy and his short
one hour class on skillshare
will help you stick to your habits even
after the initial novelty period wears
off he
focuses on strengthening your internal
self-discipline assisting that
self-discipline with smart external
systems that keep you on track
and improving those habits over time
with regular reflection over 45
000 people have already taken thomas
frank's class on skillshare and not one
of them has started a forest fire
skillshare as you know is an online
learning community that has tens of
thousands of classes on everything like
illustration creative writing music and
productivity
the first 1 000 legal eagles will get
two free months of skillshare premium
when you click on the link in the
description
plus after that trial ends skillshare is
way more affordable than most online
learning platforms with
plans starting at less than ten dollars
per month plus clicking on that link in
the description
really helps out this channel and it's
way cheaper than paying 37 million
dollars for damage from a forest fire
so just click on the link below and get
two free months of skillshare
so do you agree with my analysis should
we jail all people that throw gender
reveal parties or
just those that start forest fires leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist over here with
all my other real law reviews where i
talk about
all of the things that are in the legal
news from the trump administration to
covid
you name it it's all here so click on
this playlist and i'll see you
in court